okay you just gotta monitor what's going
on because i just i yeah i don't like to
i didn't like to party i just like to
put myself in a crazy situation
yeah me too you know i was that's what i
was thinking about the whole time you're
saying that i go yeah
i don't miss the drugs i miss the six
o'clock on a diner or
waking up and some girl gives you an
audi to drive home
yeah you're like what the [ __ ] just
happened last night yeah dude i was in
louisville one time i came out of a show
they had a big group in a limousine they
invited me to go to after party with
them right
i was like i'm only coming if my boy can
come in like who's your boy
and i'm like le cedric they had a
brother nearby right wearing this louis
vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and i
didn't even talk to this dude
right i was like yeah that's my boy like
all right he can come
so i [ __ ] walk over to him looking
right in the eyes and i was like
what's up man i'm theo he's like and
uh i was like all right dude i told
these people you're my friend you ever
been in a limousine he's like nah
i was like all right come get him with
us just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there
hot chicks dudes people [ __ ] little
cedric kept saying we're friends that's
what he kept saying out loud
right not the best actor bro
what did we get to this house party it's
a nice cool [ __ ] party bro
i'm downstairs i'm in the kitchen
somebody's making us a drink i'm talking
to somebody
[ __ ] is six minutes later right here
[ __ ]
somebody scream i hear a window break
right
somebody comes running down they said
some dude just stole like four
purses out of the coat room upstairs
and [ __ ] jumped out a window
that would have been me doug and that
was [ __ ] less cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something i remember
she got pissed she was a tough girl she
was like one of those uh
what are those people that slide the
thing on the ice she said curlers
in my head i was like this is the best
[ __ ] night ever
i remember took some mushrooms one time
to a uh
party in high school because i grew up
in an area where you could just get
mushroom i mean
psychedelic mushrooms grew on everything
they grow on your [ __ ] cousin's back
if you took a long enough nap you know
and you could grow up where they're in
louisiana they grew everywhere out there
oh they grew everywhere because
everybody had something
[ __ ] in their yard and then it would
rain every single day for about a half
hour right
wow so it was just i mean you see people
picking them and eating them and
families out there enjoying them in the
afternoon i mean it was everybody was oh
it was psychedelic heaven
so no i took that bag of mushrooms to
that party right and a bunch of people
ate them who'd never had them before
uh-oh and then we played a game of
hide-and-go-seek right i was like oh no
dude you hide in another dimension i was
like
i'll count you guys go hide right oh no
and i never went to [ __ ] look for it
that was the end of the head bro this
boy timothy i've never seen that dude
again
i used to work for this group they used
to sell tattooed hamsters and guinea
pigs after uh
they tattoo them yeah they used to brand
them with concerts and raise they would
say it's tattoo just to make people not
be as
sad about it but it was a brand
of what but like a heat and ink bruh for
what like what did it say
uh 311 green day anything like a
different bands that we're coming to
town
toadies
toady's acid bath uh who else
raves whatever bruh we used to truck
these hamps into the city and [ __ ]
just vend them bro
we did man because there wasn't much
there wasn't much work in our town dude
you know you had to get what you could
get and they had a man that bred
hamsters
and uh and then they had to do the
tattoos and they [ __ ]
met up and that was a merger that's big
business you know
and they started uh a merger
they started doing it man i got me some
300
miles in my house and [ __ ] and some
other guy's like you know what man
i'm a pretty good tattoo artist
[Laughter]
that's louisiana and that's it
dude i remember when before they even
had child pornography when children were
just not you know doing that
and they had um somebody one time when i
was in college sent me a picture
of two old men and they were naked in a
room i remember getting this email oh
lemon party
and they probably seen the same image
and they had a kid like sitting on a bed
oh no i haven't seen that image
right and i in my mind i'd never thought
about
old people when children and sex you
know or anything wild like that so
i remember seeing him be like oh this is
[ __ ] hilarious
but i remember seeing him be like what a
crazy idea like you know everybody is
naked you know and so like life is naked
this is just
you know it's almost like an art like
this is how people you know it's like
this is when they're old and this is
when they're young and these guys are
you know watching tv or whatever you
know i thought
so i sent it to everybody i knew i was
like guys
this is so silly and dude i remember
like two years later running into an
ex-girlfriend
and she goes what have you been up to
with your life right
and she goes yeah well nobody will
forget that time that you sent that
picture of
two old men and a naked kid to everybody
and i was like that's what that was i'm
like that's what that was if you look at
it like a creepy [ __ ]
excommunicated by everyone you know but
i just thought it was
like i thought it was like seeing a
couple rabbits in a yard you know when
you see two rabbits on a goat's back
like in a photo
sure yeah like i thought it was like
that oh let's just
mix the world you know i didn't think of
it as sex oh my god
did you get any responses i know that
girl once when that girl told me that
then i started to feel
i mean i think that probably made me
feel bad about myself because then i
thought
i don't remember i don't even have that
account anymore i don't even know who's
on that email list
right who had seen that right that is
still looking for you
she also said the kid she goes was that
you in the photo because the kid
looked like me a little bit and that's
why i think somebody had originally sent
it to me like hey man is this you
and i was like no it's not me dude i
don't know two old people that would be
naked in a room with me
you know and just taking photos but i
wasn't thinking like oh these guys are
being dirty
you know you're like a tall in shape
good looking dude
i'd look at you and i think there's
nothing wrong in his life at all like
there's no way he's self-conscious about
anything
well that's wrong man i look at you and
i think this guy's [ __ ]
what environment got it all what
environment do you feel comfortable in
just a more real environment a more just
calm uh uh just
people 50 people 100 people yeah as long
as yeah i can feel okay in 10 50 when it
gets
to be a little more than that it's
sometimes it's just too much but when
the music's loud and i can't communicate
with people
then that's where i start to feel
uncomfortable that's my end that's my
fault but i kept going back i kept
thinking it was something wrong with me
that the environment was okay
but it wasn't man and that's what
happened that night i went to this club
and uh they had a party for my friend's
fashion line
and then i got in this taxi after this
girl gets in with me i left early
because i was gonna be on opie and jim
norton that's when obi and jim were
still together
and uh this beautiful girl gets in the
taxi with me this asian girl
and she just started talking about the
night she said that she had fun at the
party but her boyfriend wasn't in town
then she goes her boyfriend's never in
town then she's like what happens in
taxis stays in taxis right that's what
she said
so i'm thinking [ __ ] yeah you know like
she wants me to make a move on try to
make a move shut me down
and i don't know if that's what made me
feel weird after that or whatever but
the taxi dropped her off after that
and uh and then it was just me and the
driver bro this dude spoke another
language you know something
[ __ ] fancy you know something could
play soccer you know like this dude
like this dude was betting on [ __ ]
foreign soccer games on his phone for
sure
you know and uh he said i thought he
said drugs dude and i just said cocaine
that's what i said
and next you know we're in north harlem
he bought some cocaine for us
he comes back in the car we're doing
cocaine
and then he's like i got a gift for you
i got a gift you know and i thought it
was gonna be
you know i grew up in like a troubled
area i thought it was gonna be his dick
you know like i'm you know that's what i
was expecting anyway
and uh and then a hook a
prostitute knocks on the door you know
this lady gets in and i think it was a
man honestly in hindsight she had these
big sunglasses on
kind of a man's face that was under the
sunglasses you have cocktails in you at
this point
yeah a couple tequilas dude and uh so
now we're partying bruh me him and me
and the driver were first partying for
about an
hour dude i got so high i remember
thinking
where is the driver that's how [ __ ] i
was and he was sitting next to me doing
cocaine
yeah at what point does this become not
a taxicab ride
like when does the meter get turned off
like this oh the meter's going bro
the meter's at about 270 bro no so he's
gotta [ __ ] be positive because i'm
paying for this experience bro
so then dude this hooker gets in
she had kind of long hair huge
sunglasses covered about sixty percent
of her face
and the 40 of her face you you could see
to me look like a man's face right
like i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with that i'm just like if i were
on a game show and it was like guess
40 of this person's face i would have
guessed man first right you know what
i'm saying like
look at his face you know or it looked
like a woman had just shaved recently
that's what it looked like you know
so anyway we're all doing well we're all
getting high together
and the hooker starts making advances
towards me brother sounds ridiculous
and i got out of the car man i felt
uncomfortable dude
so then do you like slime you understand
in my world i'm thinking
you're a louisiana boy in [ __ ]
harlem no [ __ ] do you feel out of place
i feel out of place there but no
i always felt comfortable in north
harlem yeah like that's
i know that neighborhood where you're at
you know what i'm saying you're not in
the bronx yet
right you know yeah i don't know where
we're at oh yeah it doesn't matter
was it dark it was a dark dark that's
all that matters yeah
you're only having a good time if you're
not in a dark neighborhood
i was raising one i know when oh my god
you know i know when i'm back
now what time is all this going down
it's about 3 30.
all right so what's up so you walk out
of the cab where are you now you're
getting another cab no i'm in the street
luigi comes out after me that's the dude
i was partying with the driver
and dude you know what's crazy is he had
even one of the lights in the taxi
wouldn't go off and he made like this
little paper mache thing and put it over
the light bro
like this dude was i mean i don't think
he was homosexual but this dude was
about the most romantic [ __ ] cab
driver i've ever spent time with dude
dude it was more romantic in that taxi
than it was your [ __ ] airbnf
that's the saddest part so dude i get
out he comes out after me
he made me give him a hundred bucks
right and i gave him the hunter because
i was a little scared at this point
and i'm thinking he's going to pay the
hooker and she'll go
but then i look back over there a couple
minutes later a minute later
um and they're kissing on each other's
necks he's spending 100 with this hooker
dude he [ __ ] just got this hundred
out of me bro
wait so your taxi driver bullied you
into buying him a hooker
no he owed him money anyway but right
away he took the money luigi took the
money
i said hold on five minutes let me go
he took that money and reinvested it in
the neighborhood you know what i'm
saying
and look i respect hookers man like you
know i've been through some tough nights
man i'm not in [ __ ] north harlem
but still man i don't give a [ __ ] here's
i respect women that are out there if
they got to be out there selling their
bodies
i don't have nothing against that i know
you don't but in north harlem you ain't
getting into nothing good
you understand me are you saying north
harlem are they
i don't know i don't know east harlem
listen all i know is
i used to go to holland to buy coke and
i'd see women out there
and dog let me tell you something it's
an illusion
yeah it's an illusion first of all four
out of ten of them
got bigger dicks than you damn four four
out of ten of those chicks
you don't like those in those days it
was you gotta remember up
in harlem in those days the bronx it was
open [ __ ] corral and then the 90s the
russians came
oh yeah and i never saw it but i had
friends tell me you go to
queens and they'd be six foot russian
blondes with leopard mini skirts
that you'd give them 300 just to eat the
[ __ ] they were that
wow hot banging banging like they took
over so all the other ones the crack
hoes disappeared
yeah all that you know but it knows that
even when i was
when i got in trouble with my buddy you
know dodger and we were going over there
those hookers
yeah those city rattling fighters days
you had a that that takes a certain
nerve yeah a lot of them work at the
papa's during the daytime
no they don't work they they're at the
clinic
getting blood transfusions dude we used
to have this lady victoria miss victoria
in our neighborhood bro you could pull
up bro
you could eat her ass like 40 bucks
right she'd sit in your car window dude
just basically put her ass
in your [ __ ] car window like a
[ __ ]
to-go box you know you could if you had
somebody driving you could even have
them drive the block
and she would just sit in there like a
little side item bruh
but so this dude get luigi i give him
the 100 he gets back in the car
they're making out i'm kind of pissed
dude but i don't want to bring that
negative energy back into the car
right so i deal with my feelings out in
the street for a minute kind of process
through that
why don't you want to bring negative
feelings back into the car just because
i'm already
really extremely high man i'm under the
influence of cocaine
um it's almost 4 00 a.m uh
and i don't know these people that well
and i still need to get home and for
some reason at this point i feel like
luigi
is responsible to get me home right so i
get back in the front
seat right and they're hooking up in the
back little blow job like it's getting
real it's getting wild you know
uh and i want to still do cocaine you
know
so but i don't want to interrupt him
dude so i remember trying to quietly do
cocaine in the front seat just like okay
like like
like the softest little inhale you could
do were you watching them at any point
i was definitely listening hard
i mean uh all you smell is like kelowna
like when you walk in the middle of them
all you smells like [ __ ]
heavy duty perfume
i'm trying to remember she smelled like
violence to me in tattoo she was a
tough lady or man i mean i thought she
was a man the face looked like a man's
face to me but she had big sunglasses on
she could have been one of those taller
vietnamese people that kind of look
black at night you know
ah so we're in there and uh now i'm in
the car
and i'm trying to quietly do cocaine
dude like
just like a [ __ ] just like a
like just doing it in like an
installment like how to bump on layaway
why do you know just
like they're back there [ __ ] why
can't you just because there's something
wrong with me where
i sacrifice other people like i just
feel like i got to be considerate at all
times i don't want to interrupt them
dude
i guess i don't know man i was [ __ ] up
bro so they're partying
at one point i remember even turning my
head back and just
dumping cocaine quietly into the top of
my nose
just like just as quiet as i could be
and a cop goes by dude
cop goes by i get scared i tell luigi
i'm scared bro he don't you don't give a
[ __ ] dude that's when i realized like he
didn't care about me as much as i cared
about him i guess
and he's like you drive you drive and
that's when i got in the driver's seat
and i drove man i drove us i drove us
about a mile and a half didn't know
where i was dude
and uh and then i pulled over because a
voice in my head bro
first a voice in my head is like dude at
least you're it was like you're out here
bro you're high
you know you're doing cocaine but at
least you're making money
you know like i was working like i was
the cab driver
and that's like dude my brain is [ __ ]
up like this ain't my calf
you know i gotta pay for this and then
my brain was like you don't have a
commercial driver's license
that's what got me to pull over dude
that technicality that if a cop stopped
me that i wouldn't have one
and i pulled over i got another taxi got
back to my hotel room
finished doing my cocaine and i had to
be on opie and jim norton that morning
and it's 5 30 now dude i took three
showers bruh in 10 minutes
right i have one question yeah did you
pay luigi or did you just kind of get
out and just get into another camp
we ended up in a little bit of an
argument at the end i left a hundred
dollars on the car seat
and yelled adios had him really loud i
don't even know if he spoke spanish dude
i'm just screaming adios i'm in this
[ __ ]
hooker who had the smallest hits i've
ever seen bro
look like a man's chest but uh
then i go to opium gym dude the other
guest for the day is daryl strawberry
and i could not even feel my face dude i
couldn't even think
uh and that's when i was like this is
bad luck you know i couldn't even talk
they were asking me questions dude
i'm just i couldn't even like that
i couldn't feel my face i could all my
thoughts was coming out of my neck
like i was running on on neck thoughts
dude
[ __ ] thinking with my neck bro
so i [ __ ] sat there for three hours
bro
just roasting now i know how you feel
kind of late
i just sat there just just
boiling in my own [ __ ] drug-induced
[ __ ]
and then i [ __ ] left bro and i'm
halfway there
halfway on the walk over there i
realized i had on [ __ ]
sweatpants with jeans over them bro
horrible that's like a catheter outfit
like if you
might be getting a catheter and you
might have to stay overnight
[Music]
so
[Music]
you